عند قاعدة منحدر على
الساحل الاسكتلندي، عاش الخروف الأكثر وحدة في العالم،
لا هذه ليست قصة خيالية،
عاشت فيونا هنا في كهف لمدة
عامين على الأقل، مرحبًا عزيزتي، من
المفترض أن فيونا سقطت أسفل التل عندما
كانت صغيرة ولكن  لم يكن لدى أحد الإرادة أو
الطريقة لإنقاذها حتى الآن
وصلت فيونا، وهي تقوم بعمل
رائع للغاية. أنقذت مجموعة من خمسة مزارعين
فيونا، ونزلوا إليها ووضعوها
في كيس طعام من القماش ورفعوها
مع ثقب صغير في أنفها.  كانت فيونا
مسترخية للغاية طوال الأمر برمته بينما كنا
نربيها، وكانت في الواقع
تقضم العشب، وكان ذلك حقيقيًا للغاية
ولم أر شيئًا كهذا من قبل.
كانت فيونا تبدو هزيلةً جدًا، ولكن
حتى بعد أن نقص وزنها 20 رطلًا، كانت لا
تزال تعاني من زيادة الوزن، انظر كيف  إنها في
الواقع ممتلئة، وكان هناك نوع من السباق
لإنقاذها، وكان نشطاء حقوق الحيوان
يزورون فيونا في الأيام الأخيرة لتعويدها على الناس قبل أن
يقولوا إنهم يخططون لتربيتها، لكن
المزارعين ضربوهم وأخذوا فيونا
إلى ديلكون.  متعة المزرعة، سنمنح
منزلًا احتفاليًا حديقة مزرعة
يدفع الجمهور مقابل زيارتها،
بدأ نشطاء الحيوانات عريضة لإرسال فيونا إلى
ملاذ آمن واحتجوا خارج
المزرعة قائلين أطلقوا سراح فيونا وهو أمر
مثير للسخرية تمامًا لكن المتظاهرين
يقولون إن CH هو  سوف يتم تحويلها إلى سيرك،
هل سيتدفق الجمهور على فيونا كما
يقول العنوان الرئيسي: كل شيء بنفسي لم يعد
سيلين ديون من
[موسيقى]
الأغنام جيني موس سي إن إن نيويورك
أوه